hi I'm Lucy Thomas came from UK new wife
challenge 2010 you know fan room read
some of my vision fasika if I guess is
that social grand escape but I think
it's even here is three things reverse
we carry Eve matinee scopus for normally
harmless young generation that empowered
through education one knows everything
starts at some education I think
secondly it's time technology preaching
as provided in more people are buying in
these emoji early be innovative time
mobile technology in height of a society
and thirdly current articles critical
generation of us can build a future
article insecure transparent revival way
that's my Lot's wife